this is lucy james reading for reviewer
andrew king
solar ash is built like a skate park in
a lucid dream the ground you skate
across looks and acts like an
ocean-sized mattress pad blue and bumpy
and bouncing as you pass floating
islands are connected by grind pipes
which only emerge after you transport
glowing spores from one mushroom to
another red bulging eyeballs act as the
locks on gates made of black ooze which
you slash to gain passage much of what
you see in solar ash makes little sense
but you move through it so quickly the
boss battles you fight are so
exhilarating and the puzzles you solve
to reach them are so satisfying that the
dream logic of this world's construction
feels like the necessary slight distance
to keep the good times rolling as you
move from point a to point b
the second game from heart machine the
developer of 2016 indie gem hyper light
drifter retains that game's color
palette expect plenty of pastel blues
pinks and purples with the occasional
threatening red but changes just about
everything else hyper light drifter was
a blisteringly difficult zelda like
which presented its glitching neon
overworld from a top-down 2d perspective
solar ash meanwhile is a 3d action
platformer in which you traverse its
world on some futuristic version of
inline skates cutting up enemies with
ease solar ash presents its dreamlike
world and asks you to explore it by
jumping skating and grinding along pipes
what the two games share is a structure
that while fairly open is constantly
funneling you towards show-stopping boss
battles
not so tough after all in hyper light
drifter that open-ended structure
applied to the entire map with four
sections that could be tackled in any
order solar ash adopts a more
traditional linear structure unveiling
six increasingly wide levels one at a
time in each you must hunt down multiple
puzzles that upon completion let loose a
massive boss in each there are plenty of
audio logs and armor pieces waiting to
be found if you take some time to
explore as you set out on this quest you
take control of rey a void runner who
has travelled into the ultra void a
massive world destroying black hole in
an attempt to activate the starseed a
device the voidrunners have created in
an attempt to destroy the ultravoid when
she arrives her home planet is in the
ultravoid's grasp but rey hopes that if
she can restore power to the starseed
she can save her home planet the game
sets up too many proper nouns early on
all those terms are hurled at you by way
of an introductory slide and it
struggles to communicate what exactly
the stakes are and why we should care
but the basics are simple enough and
will be familiar to the denizens of an
earth currently staring down the barrel
of a climate emergency the planet is in
imminent danger the people in charge
have squandered every opportunity to fix
the problem
and though it may be futile a hopeful
character is trying to do what she can
to undo the damage the ruling classes
have done where rey's path diverges from
climate change efforts in our world is
that her quest involves fighting
screen-filling boss monsters called
anomalies this is the heart of solar ash
and where it takes clear inspiration
from shadow of the colossus maybe too
clear honestly there's a bird-like
anomaly that soars above the map a sword
sword-wielding anomaly that drags its
skyscraper-sized blade along the ground
and a serpent anomaly that flies just
above your head all of this will be
familiar for fans of team eco's
melancholic boss rush but solar ash
trades in that game's challenging sense
of clumsily climbing up a living hostile
creature in favor of fights that feel
like playing a 3d sonic level on a
monster the size of a city block each is
covered in black ooze that will become
lava hot after a short amount of time to
delay that moment you need to skate
across the beast slashing at flashing
pin markers as you go which will create
more pins down the line which you must
hit in time and so on
each boss takes three hits to go down
and while these battles aren't nearly as
difficult as any of the boss fights in
hyper light drifter they will push you
to learn the patterns and get a solid
handle on the controls that can be
frustrating at first it sucks to fail
repeatedly and feel unsure about how to
improve but the exhilarating sense of
speed and the cinematic grandeur of your
actions playing out atop a creature that
towers over the world below a world that
you just explored thoroughly in order to
reach this moment is impressive the
process of puzzle solving in that lower
world similarly pushes you to learn and
put to use a firm understanding of the
space before you can fight each anomaly
you need to take out multiple oozy eyes
scattered around the world below these
platforming puzzles require the same
kind of timing as the boss fights you
hit a pin to start the trial then must
make it through the obstacles before the
time runs out the solution isn't always
obvious and figuring out how to use the
tools at your disposal in concert with
the specific mechanics of each level
makes these puzzles consistently
satisfying to solve in one level for
example the ground is covered in acidic
slime once you touch it a green meter
appears on screen you have until it
turns red to reach dry land and must
wait for the meter to disappear before
entering the slime again a subsequent
level ups the ante with insta-kill magma
these aren't new mechanics games have
been doing the floor is lava since
practically the dawn of the medium but
implemented here it makes for compelling
puzzles that ask the player to
constantly think about the construction
of the space they're inhabiting in order
to successfully navigate it there's a
reason that this space is so dreamly
built solar ash takes place inside a
massive black hole after all but the
game is at its best when it isn't
treating those reasons as if they matter
all that much the late game leans a
little too heavily into the story
including swapping out these strong boss
battles in favor of a binary choice in
the game's climactic moments but most of
the time that story is where it belongs
in the background and thankfully solar
ash has some gorgeous backgrounds
[Music]
you